Новообраний предстоятель Православної церкви України
Епіфаній обіцяє, що не буде жодних захоплень
храмів московського патріархату. А також
наголошує на незалежності Православної церкви України
при тому, що і Константинополь, і українська влада
відіграли велику роль у її створенні.
Жодного захоплення храмів УПЦ МП, про що
не раз заявляли її представники, не буде, запевняє
митрополит Київський і всієї України.
Парафії, які добровільно захочуть стати частиною
єдиної української церкви, на думку Епіфанія,
мають бути прийняті. Однак без насильства або дій,
які провокуватимуть у суспільстві нестабільність.
Перехід має відбуватися виключно мирним шляхом,
переконаний предстоятель Православної церкви України.
За його словами, в Україні є чимало парафій
Московського патріархату, які хотіли б перейти
до єдиної православної церкви,
і в кожній парафії є прихожани, які готові до такого переходу.
На черзі - виробити механізм, який би дозволив зробити це правильно.
Православна церква України буде самостійною структурою
і не залежатиме від Константинополя, запевнив новий предстоятель.
При тому, що саме Константинополь надасть томос
новоствореній єдиній українській церкві.
Константинопольський патріархат, за словами Епіфанія,
як "мати-церква" сприяє і допомагає
українській православній церкві у створенні її структури.
Однак після вручення томоса ПЦУ має залишатися самостійною,
а з Константинополем підтримувати духовні відносини.
Нова українська церква буде незалежною також і від держави,
пообіцяв митрополит. Така відокремленість церков
та релігійних організацій прописана і в Конституції.
Але у процесі створення помісної церкви
українській владі не раз закидали втручання у церковні справи.
Зокрема, оглядачі дорікали президенту
за присутність і на Об’єднавчому соборі,
де оголосили про створення нової церкви та обрали її предстоятеля,
і на сцені на Софійській площі у Києві під час представлення Епіфанія.
Усі рішення щодо нової церкви,
за словами її предстоятеля, будуть формуватися
на основі норм статуту. Найперше завдання ПЦУ -
створити керівні органи після отримання томоса 6 січня.
На це, за прогнозами Епіфанія, знадобиться
близько двох місяців. До складу керівних структур
увійдуть представники усіх церков, які створили єдину церкву.